yeah the thought of getting clean and
actually having to feel this like
this being upset is is medicated
being clean and not having anything to
like numb these feelings and they have
to feel this
i don't want to honestly i don't want to
know what this feels like without
drugs
all right megan megan where are you from
cleveland
ohio cleveland and tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents when
you were a kid i did till i was about
five
and then my parents got divorced um my
mom
was on drugs she was an iv drug user
cocaine
i have seven brothers and sisters um
i don't know it's kind of [ __ ] up how
was your childhood
good and bad it was when we were with my
mom it was bad because she was on drugs
our lights were shut off we had lice no
phone
no my dad eventually got custody of us
and he was together
but it was too late by then i mean i was
molested
by two of my brothers and at that point
it was too late i didn't want to go to
school i didn't it was just
this went on for a while well i'm for
yeah for a long time
how old were you it started when i was
probably eight
until i started my period and then it
stopped
you you went through high school i
dropped out my senior year i had a son
when i was 16.
oh really and uh where'd your life go
after that
i got married actually i had a pretty
good life um then my husband and i
started doing pills
my husband's dead he overdosed um we
were on pills and then
heroin and then heroin and cocaine
together and
now i do both every day heroin and crack
heroin crack
shoot coke smoke coke whatever
i have seizures all the time from it
from doing cocaine so you started
when you were i started doing heroin
when i was 28. 28.
and then how would you support yourself
after um i put an ad on backpage
and was selling my ass on backpage
in cleveland in cleveland and then i met
um a guy that had money moved in with
him and he moved to la
so i followed him to la met a dope
dealer in la
and uh i'm cute white girl and so he
moved me into his second apartment and
it was good i had all the dope and i
wanted and then his wife found out about
me and
so now i'm kind of in between here and
there and on the streets and
and where's your child i have two
children i have a boy and a girl my son
um he's doing great
graduated um high school he's in college
i have a 15 year old daughter that's
with my
mother-in-law they're both doing well
though can you
stay in contact with your kids little
because i'm ashamed of myself i mean
shame is a big deal yeah it is
and you came to l.a how many years ago
i've only been here about a year and a
half
and what you came out here for your my
boyfriend your boyfriend
and he's back in cleveland now and i'm
here because i met a dope dealer
and i had endless drugs so that keeps
you here
yeah i just met him right now and he
gave me money give me dope
and how do you support yourself now men
men and i i don't look like an average
dope
user so people are nice to me not yet i
mean it's
you know gonna happen i got bruises all
over my body
where are you staying in the right now
i'm staying at a some guy's house i
don't know i don't even know who he is i
don't know where it is or
i just the person that's driving me
knows how to get there
[Music]
and do you i mean tell me where you're
at with all this i mean
are you are you seeing that you're
distracting someone oh i know i'm a mess
i just had a seizure the other day
almost fell and busted my head open
luckily somebody was there and caught me
i'm gonna die out here i know
if i don't quit doing what i'm doing
yeah i'm going to die
and then and i know better i know the
answer to this question but i'll ask it
anyway
nothing can get you to stop i can't
reason with you nothing it's not about
that
no my husband casket couldn't get me to
stop yeah
what do you think the core of it is is
it just you believe you deserve
no i know i don't like i know i'm better
than this
i know i'm smarter than this drugs are a
[ __ ]
thank you i don't know it's
the first thing when i open my eyes in
the morning it's what i want i want to
go get drugs
what do you think others don't people
that don't do drugs don't understand
about it
i don't know because i didn't understand
until i did it i don't know
honestly it just and now i'm physically
addicted too so
the heroine if i don't get it i get sick
so it's
it's not even a mental thing anymore
it's i'll
if i didn't have it i couldn't be
sitting here to be throwing up i'd be
hot
cold so i don't know
what's been the roughest the darkest
point
um right now yeah now it's pretty dark
there's rats running around the streets
outside it's disgusting
crazy people i almost wish i was crazy
so i wouldn't know better i wouldn't
realize how [ __ ] up this was
so how do you spend your days now what's
your typical day chasing money
just whatever i have to do to get money
this morning i've been up for two and a
half hours and i've
called my boyfriend in cleveland and
conned him into money he thinks i'm in
rehab right now
so i bullshitted him and told him i
needed stuff in rehab so he sent me
money
i called my dope dealer guy he thinks
i'm in rehab too or he thought i was
supposed to be
so just [ __ ] people all day to get
money and
because you need what you need yeah i
need what i need and want what i want
and you become cold and callous and you
just
you'll do whatever it takes again yeah
you will
especially at the end of the night when
the drugs are gone and
drugs are gone you have nowhere to go
and it's like [ __ ]
it's hard what what do you think would
would actually help you
turn the corner and climb out of this
i don't know i don't know the answer if
i knew i would do it yeah i mean people
would say rehab but then
you have to want to do rehab i don't
have money to go to rehab
i don't have insurance to go to rehab
and so the rehabs to go to might as well
be on the street because they're dirty
they're gross
so be on the street at least i'm high
yeah what's the most important lesson
you feel like you've learned
don't do drugs that's it drugs i mean
and i should know better my mom was an
iv drug user i mean i
was five years old finding hypodermic
needles in the house
i i know better than this but it's
it's hard it's hard it's takes over your
whole
brain and they're putting fentanyl in
everything cocaine i have fentanyl test
strips because
i get needles at the exchange and they
give you tests to so you can test for
fentanyl and it's in cocaine it's in
meth it's in
everything so everybody's getting
physically addicted now it's not
and once you have that physical
addiction it's it's i've ruined my body
from it it's my teeth are a mess
and the fentanyl makes it tremendously
very dangerous yeah
it'll kill it's killed my husband he
overdosed
30 brilliant guy software engineer
dead and we always thought it's not
gonna be us we can always get everything
back we can get our house back we get
our cars back we can get
our jewelry back we get all this [ __ ]
back but once somebody's dead it's
that's it you can't get it back
can't get this time back i think there's
a better chance of you
ending up dead than getting clean
probably
if i'm being honest yeah
yeah because when i leave here i'm going
to
go you as they could be it
you've been living like this since for
how many years now
uh i'm 36 i've been
since my husband died is when i've been
like kind of on the streets and
like living in hotels and doing whatever
um
for five years five years how do you see
that those five years have changed you
i'm cold i used to be caring and kind
and
funny and smile and i'm cold i don't
care about anybody if they don't if
they're not getting me my next fakes
i don't give a [ __ ] about them
do you think you're you think it might
be the fact that you're
your mom your role model was was an
addict that led you here or do you think
no i don't think so i i don't think so
i mean i'm sure that didn't help my
psyche you know but no
no i mean she's fine now she's clean
she's you know she's made her men she's
no i i brought myself here how'd your
mom do it
um she just did i don't know she lost
everything and just did it i don't know
i don't know how she i don't know how
anybody does it honestly
it consumes you my first thought in the
morning is
where am i going to get drugs my last
thought before i go to sleep
it's not even fun it's not i'm not
getting high having a good time i'm not
out dancing
laughing with my friends it's not that i
sit by myself and smoke dope and shoot
dope it's not
fun this isn't a good life these people
out here
we don't love this but it's
what it is i mean we're here
california dream right
do you feel like your less than perfect
childhood might have set the
i'm sure it didn't help i'm sure it
didn't help
my parents divorcing didn't help my mom
yeah no it didn't help but i mean we all
make our own choices you know
i don't blame anybody for but the things
you went through kind of
yeah i mean yeah you're sure you don't
deserve any better
i'm yeah i have times i think like that
you know i was molested by brothers i
was
raped in high school by a brother's
friend
um so sex means nothing so selling my
ass
means nothing because the sex means
nothing
but it's been taken from you basically
your whole life but
you might as well get something for it
right
it sucks because i know i'm better than
this
like when i actually like sit and really
like use my logical brain i know i'm
better than this
yeah here i am yeah it's almost like
there's two parts of you one part can
logically say that you're better than
this and the other part
subconsciously thinks you're not you
must
because you're intelligent and you're
you're sensible
and you know you deserve better but
there's a party that keeps pulling you
down
making this okay this is acceptable it's
my life so it has to be
i mean if i just thought how horrible it
was what's that gonna do
do you feel like you were loved ever by
my dad yeah
yeah i had a good dad he was a good guy
it was just too late he just
he came into your life of what no he was
he's always been in my life but my
parents divorced
and uh my mom had custody of us and
we didn't he didn't know and when he
found out it was it was too late
you know we didn't want to go to school
we didn't even want to brush our [ __ ]
teeth i mean we had no
you know no sense of like normal you
know
so you know he comes and takes us from
our mom and wants us to go to school and
you know
live normally we don't want that we're
like wild animals you know
so today do you have do you have friends
real
like friends no no no one you trust
no i just i actually um
just came across came into like twenty
thousand dollars
spent it in a week on drugs with one
person that person i spent it was not my
friend
it's the person that has a car and
twenty thousand dollars
well the twenty thousand dollars in my
arm and their arm and their pipe my pipe
yeah one week
what's the most degrading thing you've
done for money now
some sexual thing something sexual i
don't know specifically because there's
been so
much i mean
i mean just last night i was down on
skid row
in somebody's car and there went down on
me
and somebody comes up to the window
while they're doing it because they
thought
i'm a hooker and they want me to leave
with them like and that wasn't even for
money that was just because i'm partying
with them so
why not
that's a crazy life you're living are
you able to step out of it and look at
yourself and go man
what have i done i do and that makes it
worse
because then i have to look at it and
it's that's a big pill to swallow
yeah the thought of getting clean and
actually having to feel this like
this being upset is is medicated
being clean and not having anything to
like numb these feelings and they have
to feel this
i don't want to honestly i don't want to
know what this feels like without
drugs because it's i've done a lot of
bad stuff
a lot of bad stuff
therapy might be the answer climbing out
of this
i think i'm beyond therapy
what's your biggest regret
pick one i guess i'd have to be using in
the first place because that's what
brought all of this here so if i never
did that i
would probably be okay
you could have picked a different family
you know i can't regret that it's i
didn't have a choice
if i could have yeah hell yeah i would
have
i mean my brothers were molested by an
uncle
so i can't blame them for doing it to me
they didn't it was done to them somebody
asked my mom
the same question like what what advice
would you give to
someone else and she said pick your
parents well yeah
yeah really i mean
but they're people too you know but yeah
it's
yeah forgiveness is the answer forgiving
yourself is the hard part yeah forgiving
yourself for giving your parents
forgiving everybody
it's the hard part i'm taking
responsibility for everything that's
gone on it's a big pill to swallow
it's a big pill to swallow
it's never enough there's never enough
money there's never enough dope
it's never enough
like i said 20 000 in a in a week and
that's no i'm not
exaggerating i'm not i'm not
bullshitting like
it was probably more because i made
money while i mean it came into this
chunk of 20 and then i made money
and gone like i have zero dollars in the
bank right now like i said i had to
hustle this morning to get money
and uh last week my bank account had
twenty thousand dollars in it
and it's not enough it's
i just want to get higher and
i don't know i don't think it's maybe i
have a death wish maybe i
i don't know if you've been suicidal or
cut yourself
i wish i had the balls to kill myself i
do i don't though
i don't have the balls if i did i
wouldn't be out here
death would be easy this is hard
skid row is hard
especially being a white woman on skid
row is really hard
that's really hard and not being from
here
these people think this shit's normal
rats and garbage cans and running down
the street
it's oh it's disgusting
it's life though i mean
all right megan well thank you for
coming in and talking with me absolutely
thank you
and i hope you turn a corner and figure
something out
me too you're still young and young and
healthy and beautiful and intelligent
thank you
all of that and here i am yeah i know
there's a common story though
i know we're all out here
ugh
you